ja jetzt also autogrammstunde mit angela
merkel auch was neues wir sind da jetzt
raus liebe zuschauerin leben zuschauer
90 minuten angela merkel nachdem sie
sechs monate lang beharrlich geschwiegen
hatte selbst gewählter politiker
karenzzeit was also ist mein land die
frage an die kanzlerin ein land in dem
sie 16 jahre lang ihren stempel
aufgedrückt hat ein land das sich nicht
zuletzt kommunikativ verändert hat ihm
mit neben und gegeneinander von politik
und gesellschaft auch danach muss die
ära merkel bewertet werden die
vertrauensfrage was muss politik heute
leisten jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns hier sind
wir jetzt wieder zurück in der alten
zeitrechnung der phoenix runde zu fünft
im studio als das sind ski
korrespondentin in der
parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung hier in berlin
professor bei handwerk wachsen ist bei
uns medienwissenschaftler an der
universität tübingen
ebenfalls professor hatten und rosa
lehrstuhlinhaber für soziologie an der
universität jena und sie leiten auch
gleichzeitig das max weber kolleg in
erfurt benannt nach dem berühmten
deutschen soziologen und schließlich
nico sigel geschäftsführer des
wahlforschungsinstituts infratest dimap
das unter anderem für die ard den
deutschlandtrend erstellt mit allen
umfragen dies hier im land zu fragen
gibt wachsen sehen sie eigentlich in
unterschied zwischen der kanzlerin und
der rentnerin angela merkel was das
kommunizieren angeht ja dass ich
definitiv also haben wir jetzt ein
gespräch erlebt das sehr persönlich war
auch ausgehend von dem journalisten der
er nach meinem geschmack zu viel
befindlichkeit abgefragt hat und zu
wenig kriegs fehler und krisen analyse
betrieben hat also es war in diesem
sinne vielleicht kein starkes gespräch
mit hoher politischer klärungs energie
sondern ein wie geht's auf dem weg zum
nächsten porträt aber definitiv sie hat
ja über die ganze kanzlerschaft und
eigentlich ihre gesamte politische
karriere hinweg ihre privaten einlassung
ihren persönlichen einlassung sehr sehr
genau dosiert es gibt ganz wenige reden
denken sie an die rede zum beginn der
pandemie 18 märz 2020 zurück denken sie
an die auch persönliche betroffene rede
nsu
wurde die gedenkfeier zurück denken sie
an die rede zum dritten oktober 2021 das
ist sicher ein unterschied jetzt dieser
persönlichere nahbarer stil wie gesagt
auch ausgelöst durch den interviews stil
des fragenden der eher unpolitisch war
nach meinem geschmack und wir haben
natürlich einen wechsel der
kommunikations modi den wir jetzt
erleben auch aktuell in der bundes
regierung wo man noch mal seht im
kontrast dazu jetzt wird nähe sehr viel
größer geschrieben jetzt gibt es ganz
andere idee den eigenen zweifel auch
dass die eigene zerrissenheit nach außen
zu tragen all das wäre angela merkel
fern gewesen dass es gibt so gut wie
keine
persönlichen geschichten über sie man
muss sie mit der lupe suchen und
insofern würde ich sagen ist dass eine
veränderung des stiers ganz gewiss sie
ist sich aber dann treu geblieben rosa
was also ist mein land der titel der
rede zum tag der deutschen einheit vor
einem knappen halben jahr auch das buch
das jetzt veröffentlicht wird trägt
diesen titel sie mir diese frage mal auf
auch wenn über das buch kaum geredet
worden ist ist sie dieser frage die
antwort schuldig geblieben was also ist
mein land oder ist sie darauf
eingegangen dass ist scheint das ist
schwer zu sagen weil ich weil ich denke
die frage wurde so gar nicht gestellt
eigentlich also da eine art von also ich
glaube es war eine starke rückschau oder
es war eine intensive rückschau auf ihre
eigenen leistungen vielleicht auch
versäumnisse nicht unbedingt auf das was
sie als ihr land begreift sie hat ja
eigentlich 2015 in einen wichtigen satz
dazu auch gesagt als sie dann als sie
ihn zur rede flüchtlingskrise gesagt hat
wenn wir jetzt anfangen müssen uns dafür
zu entschuldigen in einer notsituation
ein freundliches gesicht zu zeigen dann
ist das nicht mehr mein land womit sie
wie ich finde eine starke aussage
darüber gemacht hat wie sie das land
versteht nämlich als eine art von von
von auch von einem gemeinwesen das
durchaus eine solide solidarischen sinn
hat und in notsituationen auch in der
lage ist vielleicht von bestimmten
prinzipien oder vorgefassten
regeln abzuweichen was ich glaube dass
sehr wichtig ist heute hat sie glaube
ich einfach staat auch geleitet durch
die fragen an noch einmal rückschau
betrieben und hat da glaube ich einen
interessanten punkt immer wieder gemacht
wenn ich ihr zugehört habe nämlich dass
wir tatsächlich alle vorsichtig fahren
sollten nicht den so genannten rückschau
fehler zu begehen dass wir nämlich aus
der heutigen sicht
das ist eine rückschau fehler oder hinzu
es ist ein begriff aus der
kognitionspsychologie der auch im im
jura in der rechts im rechtswesen eine
große rolle spielt das nämlich aus einer
aus der rückschau dinge wesentlich
gradliniger zuvor laufen scheinen als
sie das tun wir beides ist man schlauer
das ist aber der scheint mir jetzt sehr
wichtig tun sollen wenn man jetzt die
rede kam logischerweise immer wieder auf
den korea krieg und das sieht ja so aus
als hätte es gar nicht woanders hin
laufen können und ich finde in dem sie
noch einmal die verschiedenen stationen
immer wieder thematisiert hat konnte man
schon deutlich sehen oder hat sie
versucht deutlich zu machen dass es eben
keine gerade linie dahin war auch dass
man ist auch in der vor also im
damaligen zeitpunkt nicht so klar vor
uns in sachen angela merkel müsse
trotzdem eine rückschau bei 93 prozent
ging an gleich gefühlt um den ukraine
krieg nichts hat ja
uns so sehr verändert oder nicht so sehr
verändert letzter zeit wie unser neuer
blick gezwungenermaßen auf russland da
wird ja auch von angela merkel selbst
kritik an ihrer früheren politischen
haltung erwartet wie hat sie dafür die
reagiert er hat sich anders zb als
steinmeier
nicht hat sehr explizit gesagt sie
entschuldigt sich nicht sie bittet nicht
um entschuldigung hat dann nochmals
vergleich was ich fast ein bisschen
humoristisch fand diese oster ruhe
angebracht und die man sich ja nur
deshalb erinnert weil sie sich damals
dafür entschuldigt hat das war eine
petitesse sondergleichen also zwei tage
vor ostern die die schulen zu sein
sollten die dann doch nicht zum
geschlossen wurden da hat sie das
einzige mann ihrer kanzlerschaft wo sie
öffentlich um entschuldigung gebeten hat
so und er hat sie gesagt im gegensatz
dazu hat sie in der ukraine krieg gibt
es keinen grund um entschuldigung zu
bitten und das hat sie das unterscheidet
sie eben von von steinmeier mit dem sie
ja teile der politik gemeinsam gemacht
hat sie hat aber und da finde ich ist
sie sich sehr insgesamt treu geblieben
sie hat erklärt warum sie ihre politik
wie gemacht hat sie den vorwurf von sich
gewiesen in irgendeiner weise naiv
gewesen zu sein sie hat also auch nicht
gesagt was ja ansonsten gerade in der
spd ein üblicher modus ist man habe sie
in putin geirrt sie habe deutlich
gemacht dass sie sich da nie illusionen
gemacht hat hat aber erklärt warum sie
bestimmte entscheidungen etwa zu dem 2
trotzdem so getroffen hat und hat
eigentlich da also das was man so auch
dieses teflon image ja diese teflon
kanzlerin finde ich hat ein stück weit
ist sie heute noch gewesen dass manche
gar nicht nur abwerten sondern sie hat
im grunde genommen gesagt man kann es
auch anders sehen aber ich sehe so mit
einem ziemlichen selbstbewusstsein das
vorgetragen und ihre sie sagt dann ja
immer es geht hier nicht um die legacy
aber man hat eben schon den eindruck sie
verteidigt da eben doch auch ein ganzes
stück ihrer politik diese ja als als
ostdeutsche als russischsprachige als
russland kennerin sie hat ja auch
erzählt etwa von den ausflügen da in
ihrer jugend den man ihr natürlich
ansonsten hätte machen können und der ja
auch gemacht wird
olaf scholz sei eine fortsetzung von
angela merkel mit wenig anderen mitteln
wird ja immer wieder gefrotzelt der stil
der beide verbindet der ist angela
merkel ja offensichtlich ziemlich gut
bekommen olaf scholz er nicht sind das
nur die unterschiede jetzt mit den
erfahrungen des krieges gegen die
ukraine oder das oder spielte auch eine
rolle was helene profs gerade gesagt hat
dass sie doch so etwas wie eine teflon
kanzlerin war ja ich denke olaf scholz
ähnlichkeit mit angela merkel im sinne
von sehr rationales entscheiden eine
gewisse ruhe ausstrahlen auf der vorwurf
natürlich von den medien er braucht zu
lange um entscheidungen zu treffen das
sind ja die gleichen kritiken die wir
über angela merkel quasi fortwährend
während der kanzlerschaft gezeigt werden
gereichen ihm im moment teilweise zum
nachteil weil eben selber mal ein
mainstream sagt er muss schneller
entscheiden entschlossener entscheiden
wobei es natürlich aus sicht der
bürgerinnen und bürger die in dieser
frage komplett gespalten sind durchaus
gute argumente gibt abzuwägen und gerade
bei fragen wenn es um krieg und frieden
und militärische unterstützung geht
grundsätzlich die prinzipien klar zu
machen er hat ja von einer zeitenwende
gesprochen ich glaube keiner von uns
hätte im februar gedacht ist an eine
zeitenwende kommt dann vier wochen
später schon die
verteidigungspolitischen strategien
konkrete aktionen umgemünzt wird also
langfristig ist es nicht wahrscheinlich
dass eben das zum nachteil gereicht er
regiert in einer völlig anderen
konstellation erstmals ein ampel bündnis
auf bundesebene gibt es große
unterschiede
über die ukraine genaues wenn sie das
corona management nehmen sie
grundsätzliche fragen des sozialstaates
sind grundsätzliche fragen zum
verhältnis von staat und markt sind
diese drei parteien viel weiter
auseinander als die beiden klassischen
volksparteien wir wollen vielleicht noch
im moment bei der ex kanzlerin bleiben
jörg sundermeier immer der vorwurf sie
würde auf sicht fahren sie habe die
dinge immer laufen lassen hatte spät
oder im allerletzten moment erst
reagiert und das habe
politikverdrossenheit geradezu
provoziert darüber reden wir ja auch
jetzt auch zur politik der ampel
koalition was ist denn an diesem vorwurf
richtig und das ist nicht richtig also
nicht richtig ist dieses bild das man
damit von sich selbst bzw ist die
bürgerinnen und bürger von sich selbst
malen oder zeigen wenn man so tut als
habe angela merkel gleichsam im
alleingang den diskursen
kommunikationsstil in diesem land
bestimmt und politikverdrossenheit nun
als alleinige verursacherin befördert
aber richtig ist aus meiner sicht an
dieser vorhaltung natürlich war diese
rede von auf sicht fahren die formel für
ihr uhr pragmatisches vorgehen natürlich
hat sie keine große reform erzählungen
geliefert keine zukunfts erzählung die
es auch aus strategischen gründen
natürlich hat sie in wahlkämpfen die
orte sind der politisierung in massiver
weise eine strategie betrieben die man
asymmetrische mobil demobilisierung
genannt hat also die gegenseite soll
nicht richtig wach werden und
gewissermaßen zitiert werden auch damit
ist eine politisierung chance vergeben
worden und natürlich hat sie themen auch
immer wieder abgeräumt und nicht
diskutiert gerade nicht diskutiert also
es ist ja auch eine kanzlerschaft und
das sage ich mit einer sympathie für
angela merkel aber seine kanzlerschaft
er nicht gehaltenen reden gewesen also
den atomausstieg nicht erklärt keine
große rede zu dem thema existenziellen
thema unserer zeit der klimakrise der
die formel wir schaffen das ist eine
überschrift aber es hat sehr lange
gedauert bis der text kam die ehe für
alle all das sind beispiele in denen die
auseinandersetzung auch in kontroverser
politisieren da auch die mitte mo
politisierende art und weise gerade
nicht geführt wurde dass jemand 16 jahre
kanzler oder kanzlerin bleibt ist ja
äußerst ungewöhnlich dass muss einen
grund haben sie ja selbst gesagt vier
wahlen gewonnen
wenn man das jetzt aus dieser sicht
heute sieht muss ich ja ziemlich viel
richtig gemacht haben oder war das
einfach der zeit geschuldet oder zahlen
jetzt zugespitzt geht die zeche für die
16 jahre angela merkel wo eben diese
zuspitzung nicht stattgefunden hat diese
profilierung wo es wenig strategische
diskussionen wenig visionen gab dies
eigentlich in der zukunft weitergehen
soll denn die zukunft ist das was alle
interessiert
[Musik]
naja man kann halt sagen dass in
deutschland ein ist ein großes bedürfnis
gibt nach politischer stabilität wenig
neigung zu politischen experimenten ja
also menschen mit großen visionen das
wusste schon helmut schmidt den
misstrauen deutsch ich würde die these
wagen dass jemand wie boris johnson in
deutschland keine chance hätte das sieht
man ja jetzt auch
die kontinuitäten von zwischen angela
merkel und und olaf scholz ich glaube es
gibt auch beträchtliche unterschiede
zwischen den beiden arbeit das in womit
sie sich einig sind ist natürlich dieses
image sie kennen mich ja sie können mir
vertrauen ja ich war vorher vizekanzler
jetzt bin ich ganz bei mir ich bin ein
ruhiger steuermann und stehe am vorne
und fahre sozusagen aufsicht und ich
kann nichts passieren das ist
offensichtlich könnte man jetzt mit dem
soziologen darüber reden woher das kommt
in deutschland diese skepsis gegenüber
visionen die auch angela merkel ganz
stark teilt ich glaube bei ihr ist es
verständlich wenn wir in der ddr
aufgewachsen ist und sozusagen eine von
ideologie geprägt die jugend hat der hat
wahrscheinlich internalisiert eine
skepsis gegenüber visionen aber das ist
meine ich in deutschland verbreitet ein
starkes bedürfnis nach verlässlichkeit
nach vertrauen nach sicherheit und da
kommen halt solche politiker typen gut
an und sag ich mal das
verrückteste was man sich dann noch
traut ist so eine art von begeisterung
für robert habeck der aber im grunde
genommen auch vernünftige politik
erklärt und und und seine vision
beschränkt sich auch auf vernünftige
ziele die einen kleinen schritten
erreichen will
gute sachen in sachen vision in der
politik können wir mit dem soziologen
hier im studio mit hat ist ja auch
sprechen olaf scholz ist jetzt auch
nicht bekannt für vision jetzt kommt bei
ihm ja noch dazu dass er den eindruck
macht er sei ein getriebener der ohne
klare ansage und scheinbar auch ohne
irgendwo eine agenda
gerade regiert und wenn er dann doch
kommuniziert oder wenn man das gefühl
hat oder wenn er selbst das gefühl hat
dass er eigentlich eine agenda hat dann
kommuniziert kommuniziert er das zu
wenig was ist denn daran richtig und was
ist daran falsch dass olaf scholz
möglicherweise ideen hat gute ideen hat
auch gute politische ansätze gibt noch
keiner mit
ich war natürlich ist politische
kommunikation heute sehr sehr schwierig
also man kann sich darüber streiten ob
es früher anders gewesen wäre aber es
ist so dass mit jedem also eigentlich
auch jeder versuch an die vision zu
formulieren natürlich von allen seiten
und gerade auf einen sozialen medien mit
ganz schnell mit er auch hohen
empörungswelle rechnen muss was ich
glaube schon dazu führt also was
wenigstens beim menschen wie olaf schulz
dazu führt dass sie sich sehr sehr
konservativ im blick auf visionen da
äußern wir haben andere politiker typen
gesehen wie donald trump oder boris
johnson wobei ich mir da nicht sicher
bin ob man da wirklich von vision reden
kann ich würde sagen nach hinten was
allerdings die politikverdrossenheit
angeht müssen wir ja sehr deutlich sehen
dass das kein deutsches problem ist also
in frankreich ist die
politikverdrossenheit in rom mit um
nicht zu sagen gigantisch in england
eigentlich auch also mit wem sie reden
england oder in großbritannien sagen die
leute wir schämen uns für das was wir
politisch zu bieten haben eigentlich
beiden hat sich auch nicht durch große
visionen hervorgetan ich glaube
möglicherweise gibt das
gesamtgesellschaftliche gründe
gesellschaft strukturelle gründe die man
nicht einfach politikern in die schuhe
schieben könnte frederik james ein
amerikanischer kultur wissenschaft lag
schon vor jahren geschrieben ist es
eigenartig dass unser zeitalter sich
dadurch auszeichnet dass wir jede menge
apokalypsen zeichen können bilder für
den untergang und ganz wenig
motivierende eine vision hervorbringen
wenn man jetzt olaf scholz
bewertet
und ihnen versucht auch da gerecht zu
werden erwarten denn die deutschen
vielleicht die deutsche bevölkerung
gar keine vision wollen die wie bei
angela merkel mit klaren richtlinien mit
rationalität mit vernunft mit
berechenbarkeit regiert werden in 16
merkel jahren gab es kaum
arbeitslosigkeit gut wie keine inflation
wirklich ein kräuter viel
wirtschaftswachstum verdankt sie
vielleicht auch ihrem vorgänger aber ist
dass so etwas was den deutschland sowie
so abgeht division einen aufschlag zu
machen wo will ich hin ein großes bild
der zukunft zu malen geht uns das nach
wie vor ab im meinungsbild der deutschen
naja in den radikalen rinteln gibt es
visionen die kann man dann eher als
negative vision vielleicht darstellen in
der mitte ist der geschmack dafür schon
deutlich weniger ausgeprägt die
deutschen von der politischen kultur
wenn man das auch international
vergleich haben sich immer durch das was
man sagen kann sichtlichen ernst
gegenüber dem staat ausgezeichnet und
wünschen sich einen sehr seriösen
staatenlenker das spielt genau diesen
politikstil von angela merkel und olaf
scholz in die hand gleichwohl haben wir
zuletzt bei verschiedenen studien
festgestellt dass der anteil derer die
sich weitreichende politische reformen
wünscht in deutschland steigt und zwar
nicht nur unter den jungen wie das
häufig behauptet es geht über die
alterskohorten hinweg und das hauptthema
ist dort natürlich allen voran
klimapolitik sozial ökologische
transformation unserer marktwirtschaft
ist digitalisierung und trotzdem würde
ich auch noch mal ganz kurz mal sagen
was zu diesen 16 jahren angela merkel
hinzu gehört ist natürlich das große
reformen eigentlich immer nur unter
einem großen situativen druck entstanden
sind sie hatte nicht diese vision des
wandels wie ein willy brandt die hat
aber seinen nachfolger auch als zurzeit
wo gerade mit helmut schmidt auch nicht
gehabt und helmut kohls geistig
moralische wende ist relativ schnell
innenpolitisch verpufft sie hat zweitens
bei allem was man sagen kann zur
nachlassenden bindekraft von parteien in
deutschland es besser verstanden als die
mehrheit der staatschef in den
westeuropäischen demokratien die ränder
relativ klein zu halten und sie hat eben
auch es geschafft in wichtigen
gesellschaftlichen fragen die
polarisierung ein zudem bei der
flüchtlingskrise es ist nicht gelungen
da gab es dann eben das erstarken der
afd eines hat sie nicht geschafft und
das bleibt in diesem interview völlig
unerwähnt 14 von 16 jahre hatten wir
wirtschaftswachstum mit ausnahme 2009
finanzkrise mit ausnahmen 2020 erstes
corona
also 14 jahre wachstum und am ende
dieser wachstumsperiode sagen 80 prozent
der deutschen der wohlstand ist nicht
gerecht verteilt auch die anhänger der
cdu und der fdp sagen dass sie hat es in
dieser phase nicht geschafft diesen
diese wirtschaftliche progression gibt
in zumindest die wahrnehmung unter den
bürgerinnen und bürger dass dort
ausreichend teilhabe möglich war wenn
man sich das sozialbudget anschaut wenn
man sich andere objektive indikatoren
anschaut kann man so ganz
unterschiedlichen schlussfolgerungen
kommen aber in der wahrnehmung vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger gab es nicht
diese teilhabe an diesem
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt und das
holt dann letztendlich mit einem
bestimmten verzögerung auch wieder
bestimmte diskussionen über parteien
oder politikverdrossenheit 1 über noch
einmal auf angela merkel kurz schauen
das war ja so etwas wie die einen
vortrag von ihr wie sie sich jetzt ihre
neue rolle die versteht diese die sieht
und wir haben einen kurzen ausschnitt
noch den wollen wir uns jetzt zum
abschluss des kapitels angela merkel
hier nochmal ansehen wie sie ihre neue
rolle jetzt hinein wachsen will nachdem
sie nach 16 jahren eben nicht mehr
kanzlerin ist ich bin bundeskanzlerin
ade ich bin keine ganz normale bürgerin
in dem sinne nicht dass ich fast noch
vorsichtiger sein muss zu den heutigen
aktuellen dingen was zu sagen als jeder
der von ihnen die herkunft war ja immer
merkt sagt so und scholz hat aber gesagt
und die hart gesagt und dann hat man es
steht man wieder plötzlich voll im
politischen leben das ist nicht meine
aufgabe ist kommentare von der
seitenlinie zu geben die und trotzdem
bin ich nicht neutral in diesem konflikt
so und jetzt ist meine hoffnung
nach wie vor ich suche ja noch nach
meinem weg was ist eine bundeskanzlerin
die ich habe im büro wie ich gelesen
habe auch ein sehr großes ich habe ein
schönes büro
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern und
ich finde eine bundeskanzlerin die ja
auch von den menschen gewählt wurde vier
mal die hat schon auch die aufgabe wenn
es gut laufen sollte noch ein bisschen
etwas für das land zu tun und wenn
gewünscht wird das land zu
repräsentieren aber eins haben mir auch
vorgenommen weil ich will jetzt nicht
immer nur wieder termine abarbeiten wo
mich jemand einlädt sondern ich möchte
etwas machen was mir freude macht und
damit trotzdem etwas für das land sein
kann und wenn ich dann lese ja
wäre es keine journalisten schelde
betreiben aber wohl fühlt hermine
merkels leicht sich zurück und macht
jetzt nur noch wohl viele termine da sag
ich ja
eher was kann sie denn für das land noch
tun also soll ein hilfe von der
seitenlinie wir sind nicht machen sie
sich nicht einmischen das ist jetzt eine
erstaunliche erkennen ist und was kannst
du für dieses land noch tun wie den 16
jahren naja wenn man auf dem buckel wenn
man jetzt an der gerhard schröder denkt
kann man sagen weil sie kann vor allem
viel für das land tun indem sie sich
korrekt verhält sage ich mal so ja indem
sie nicht also es ist jetzt negativ
definiert ja aber indem sie nicht
deutsche interessen verrät indem sie
nicht käuflich ist in dem sie nicht
dieses bild war es ja über 16 jahre sie
und das finde ich eine wirklich
einzigartige leistung dass sie es
geschafft hat 16 jahre
zu überstehen ohne einen einzigen
politischen skandal ohne einen also man
kann über ihre politik unterschiedlicher
meinung sein aber dass sie eine integre
person ist die ganz sich in ihr leben in
den dienst des staates gestellt hat mit
allem die bitteren einschnitten was das
für ihr leben für ihre gesundheit und so
weiter bedeutet sich selbst nie geschont
hat das muss man glaube ich sagen da
sind sich meine ich auch alle einig und
dass sie dieses bild glaube ich nicht
einreißt das sehe ich aber auch
überhaupt gar kein anderer anhaltspunkte
warum sie das tun sollte weil das glaube
ich auch ihrer persönlichkeit entspricht
das ist dann glaube ich etwas wo man
dann auch sagen kann unabhängig davon ob
man jede entscheidung von ihr teilt oder
nicht das man stolz sein kann dass diese
frau dieses land regiert hat was ja auch
viele aus dem ausland sind also es ist
ein bisschen auch in wellen jahr gibt es
immer mal wieder momente wo wo ein
ausländische kollegen angesprochen haben
gesagt habe was habt ihr für eine tolle
kanzlerin und ob sie die momente wo das
nicht so stark ausgeprägt war aber
insgesamt hat sie ja
mit den dingen die sie auch nicht
gemacht hat trotzdem 16 jahre dieses
land gut regiert das ende ihrer amtszeit
häufiger gefallen ist wir werden uns
noch nach ihrer kanzlerschaft zähnen
denn würde man heute nicht mehr sofort
ich finde es interessant ich habe jetzt
bei mir selber gedacht ich habe kürzlich
war nachgedacht und dachte ich habe sie
gar nicht vermisst also man hat
irgendwie gar nicht was ich ursprünglich
anders dachte dass das alles chaotisch
werden würde und dass man diese diesen
diese mischung irgendwie aus aus
sachlicher politik und so weiter und ein
bisschen auch dieser witz ja heute so
durchziehen wie dass man das vielleicht
vermissen würde gehen wir gar nicht so
heute als ich dann wieder gesehen habe
dachte ich so naja sie hatte schon in
einer art an die man sich natürlich auch
gewöhnt hat die man jetzt lange nicht
mehr erlebt hat dass man als ich
vermisse sie jetzt nicht das kann ich so
nicht sagen ich glaube auch nicht dass
ich glaube auch wirklich 16 jahre sind
genug und wahrscheinlich waren es
vielleicht sogar viel über den durst
aber
dass sie dass sie irgendwie was ganz
besonderes hat ja das hat man glaube ich
heute auch wieder sehen können also
angela merkel hat uns etwas hinterlassen
durch ihre kanzlerschaft und jetzt durch
die tatsache dass sie nicht mehr im amt
ist jetzt sind andere im amt eigentlich
kann man ja sagen seit 2008 ist die
krise in der deutschen politik also
beginnen mit der euro-krise eine art
dauerzustand geworden
erst für merkel und jetzt natürlich erst
recht noch für olaf scholz wird das den
normalzustand in der politik bleiben die
krise das normale sein und was bedeutet
das eigentlich für eine gesellschaft
also ich fürchte dass das so ist ich
meine man kann sagen in gewisser weise
ist hat es nicht erst 2008 begonnen ich
meinte der französische historiker rolle
sagt das bewusstsein modernen zu sein
war immer das bewusstsein in einer krise
zu leben seit der französischen
revolution hat das gar nicht aufgehört
aber natürlich gibt es da immer noch
trotzdem noch unterdrücken mindestens
graduelle unterschiede und es ist
tatsächlich so dass in den letzten
2008 vielleicht vielleicht kann man auch
vorher anfangen da gab es den irakkrieg
da gab es 2001 also eigentlich die
kriegt man hat das gefühl die krisen
serien kommen näher und näher und ich
glaube aber das entscheidende für die
gesellschaft ist dass das normal nachdem
wir uns vielleicht zähnen selber
krisenhaft ist oder krisenhafte war
hatte klimakrise sozusagen war ja teil
des normalen zustand ist oder der
normalzustand hat das erzeugt und viele
bürger bürger hatten das gefühl und
haben das immer noch dass der dass der
normalmodus nämlich jedes jahr schneller
laufen zu müssen als im jahr zuvor jedes
jahr wachstum zu produzieren immer zu
innovativ zu sein dass das selber eine
krisenhafte form ist die auch die
menschen psychische zum teil überfordert
hat sieht man an burn out raten
depressionen angsterkrankungen und so
etwas und ökonomisch scheint die krise
auf eine dauerkrise zu sein also
gleichzeitig wachstumsraten zu steigern
und die klimakrise zu bekämpfen und dazu
noch den menschen so viel zeit und
freiräume zu liefern dass sie ein
entspanntes leben führen können ist
quasi ausgeschlossen also das alte
normal nachdem wir uns auf zähnen ist
eigentlich ein sehr pathologisches wenn
das krisenhafte oder die krisensituation
das neue normal ist könnte man sich da
auch kommunikativ dran gewöhnen dass man
vielleicht auch so dass man ist nicht
mehr so entspannt weil ständig eine
krise die andere jagt aber
möglicherweise sogar einen
gewöhnungseffekt dass man sagen kann
vielleicht wäre das auch wenn wir das
akzeptieren dass wir von einer krise in
die andere kommen und da vielleicht auch
gar nicht mehr rauskommen dass man sich
dann überlegt wie können wir damit zu
umgehen dass wir vielleicht wieder etwas
entspannter kommunizieren es gibt diese
gewöhnungseffekte wir sehen uns ja auch
eine beginnende kriegsmüdigkeit die
washington post hat vor ein paar tagen
von der ukraine fertig geschrieben wir
haben entsprechende studien die zeigen
die menschen
nehmen sich raus schalten die medien ab
die spendenbereitschaft sinkt die
demonstration sind nicht mehr so
intensiv also es gibt diese krisen
müdigkeit nach wenigen wochen sechs
setzt die einen wir haben es bei der
pandemie gehabt wir erleben es mit blick
auf die klimakrise die das besondere
problem hat dass sie nicht in dieser
weise im verhältnis zu ihrer
existenziellen relevanz medial
aufrütteln darstellbar ist und wir
erleben es auch mit blick auf den krieg
aber ich würde sagen dass für die
politische kommunikation das tatsächlich
einen in der dimension neue
herausforderung ist ich stimme herrn
rosa vollkommen zu die menschen erleben
diese
diesen normalität bruch wie reagiert
jetzt politische kommunikation für mich
ist es eine der tiefen ursachen warum
olaf scholz derzeit kommunikativ so
kritisiert wird dass er keine antwort
findet auf gewissen das den resignation
style dass die krisen verdichtung das
katastrophische uhr gefühl der stapelung
von klimakrise pandemie die noch nicht
vorbei ist und diesem krieg nur wenige
tausend kilometer von uns entfernt
und hier finden und das ist auch neu
diese konkurrenz hatte angela merkel
nicht in ihrem team da konnte sie
gewissermaßen einsamen mit ihrem stil
stärker wirken hier finden die grünen in
der gestalt von robert habeck oder von
angela berbalk einen anderen stil und
der heißt würde ich sagen dilemma
bewusste offenheit sichtbar machen dass
wir diese krisen die sie beschrieben
haben gar nicht in ihrer dimension
sofort lösen können sichtbar machen dass
handlung ungeheuer schwer ist aber doch
das eigene bemühen offenlegen die eigene
zerrissenheit offenlegen die eigenen
zweifel offen legen und diesen stil in
richtung einer dosierten offenheit in
eine richtung eines dosierten zweifels
in richtung einer dosierten
zerrissenheit wir wollen ja nicht wie
bei frau spiegel diese total
privatisierung des politischen da fühlen
sich menschen auch abgestoßen diesen
stil
der wirkt deshalb so stark weil er aus
meiner sicht zeitgemäßer ist und olaf
scholz vielleicht auch aufgrund seiner
eigenen persönlichkeit
sich nicht dem
sinn hingezogen fühlt und anders gelernt
hat denken sie zurück an seine zeit als
generalsekretär die ja unter gerhard
schröder die hartz-iv-reform
gewissermaßen stoisch maximalstufe ist
verteilt und dieses hier glauben dieses
stück genau dieses muster und das bloß
weg moderieren dieses muster
funktioniert nicht mehr die
erreichbarkeit zeigen für die krise für
das krisen gefühl reagieren können aber
ohne
zu sagen so zu tun als hätte man die
perfekte lösung diese
kommunikationsstrategie habeck werbung
entspricht die tatsächlich eine
erwartungshaltung können sie das
bestätigen
menschen jetzt an die politik gerade
weil es diese zäsur nach angela merkel
gegeben hat wo sich soviel innen wie
außenpolitisch geändert hat haben die da
voll ins schwarze getroffen die beiden
oder war das eher zufall wie wie ist
diese erwartungshaltung der wählerinnen
und wähler gegenüber persönlichkeiten
denn die beiden stehen ja weit an der
spitze der beliebtheitsskala
sowas kann sich im zeitverlauf auch
ändern nicht also insofern sollten wir
das erstmal beobachten habe ich glaube
ich stimme dem vollkommen zu dass eines
der politischen dilemma tat ist derzeit
ist der politik ob bundesregierung
landesregierung bis auf die kommunale
ebene kommuniziert so viel wie nie zuvor
auf so unterschiedlichen wegen wie nie
zuvor
also wenn man die intensität der pr
terminkalender eines olaf scholz oder
eines der bundesminister vergleicht mit
vor 20 40 oder 50 jahren dann würde man
sagen da gab es sehr gemütliche zeiten
den bonn am rhein oder gab es ein paar
hauptstadtjournalisten die hat man dann
mal zum mittagessen eingeladen hat alles
durchgesprochen nächsten morgen kam es
dann in der zeitung und diese enorme
beschleunigung der politischen
kommunikation geht übrigens an den
meisten bürgern vorbei also wir eliten
reden ständig darüber aber die meisten
menschen mit dem durchschnittliche
interesse verfolgen nicht mehrmals am
tag die politischen nachrichten
und sie sehnen sich einerseits nach
klarer führung und nach klarer
transparenter kommunikation
die aber erschwert wird in dieser medien
offenheit in dieser medienöffentlichkeit
der heutigen zeit weil eben jeder kleine
fehler sofort sichtbar wird ja und dann
dann kommuniziere ich so risikoavers wie
es olaf scholz und angela merkel machen
so und jetzt kommen an einen punkt wo
sich womöglich die anforderungen ändern
weil eben viele jetzt auch nach diesen
16 jahren seit ich habe jetzt genug von
diesem politiker spreche also wir wissen
aus einer vielzahl von studien a die
deutschland drin für andere stiftungen
etc pp dass die menschen häufig mit der
kommunikation nicht zufrieden sind es
ein zwei punkte haben das erste ist es
ist nicht offen und klar politiker
müssen klar machen in der ukraine krise
dass die deutsche politik nicht
omnipotent ist die deutsche politik wir
diesen konflikt
nicht alleine lösen können sie kann nur
einen wichtigen beitrag im europäischen
konzert liefern und diese relativierung
deren robert habeck zum beispiel an den
tag legt die kommt bei vielen menschen
an weil sie ein realistisches bild auf
die politik gibt die die die
handlungsfähigkeit der politik sind im
bereich wirtschaft im bereich recht im
bereich außen und sicherheitspolitik
begrenzt und politiker neigen und da
muss man sagen in dieser ukraine krise
besonders zwei worte zu nehmen die man
eigentlich einer vernünftigen
kommunikationsstrategie vermeiden sollte
sofort und unmittelbar zu handeln weil
das überhaupt nicht im wesen der
demokratie von koalitionsregierung ist
und das zweite alles zu tun die politik
wird nie alles tun um irgend ein
isoliertes gesellschaftliches problem zu
lösen sie wird immer ein ziel konflikten
zwischen verschiedenen problemen sich
bewegen ist auch das was angela merkel
gesagt es ist nicht so dass man jetzt
von morgens bis abends nur die ukraine
krise auf dem kabinettstisch hat es gibt
andere themen die ebenso stattfinden
müssen und deshalb ist diese neue
stieger kommunikation unter umständen
etwas zeitgemäße und kommt ganz
sympathisch an ob das auf dauer hält es
wird eine ganz andere frage um die
potenz der politik die wird quasi
simuliert obwohl sie gar nicht vorhanden
ist das führt dann bei der gesellschaft
bei den wählerinnen beispiel
präsentationen bürger zur enttäuschung
zur frustration ist das inzwischen schon
so in einen art gesellschaftlichen
erschöpfungszustand übergegangen oder
ist das zu hart ausgedrückt nein ich
glaube tatsächlich dass man sowas
wenigstens anzeichen sieht von so was
wie einen kollektiven gesellschaftlichen
burnout in gewisser weise übrigens nicht
nur in deutschland oder auch nicht nur
in also auch in den neuen demokratien in
mittelosteuropa sieht man social der
extreme wahlmüdigkeit auch der
bevölkerung ich weiß aber gar nicht
genau also was sie sagt man kann nicht
alles sofort entscheiden das ist
eigentlich auch genau das was olaf
scholz sagt man sich noch zurecht
sondern die anschließende therapie wer
genauer kritisiert und da sieht man
natürlich diesen schreien den
widerspruch ich glaube dass diese norm
die potenz anspruch nicht unbedingt nur
die oder gar nicht in erster linie die
politikerinnen und politiker erzeugen
handelt ja ich meine liegt im prinzip
natürlich schon im prinzip der
volkssouveränität ja alle staatsgewalt
geht vom volke aus darlegten allmacht
versprechen ihr könnt eure lebensform
selber gestalten ist das ist eigentlich
die grundidee der demokratie dass keine
kirche kein könig nicht mal die
naturgesetze so weit dass sie
beeinflussen können bestimmen wie wir
leben und ich glaube menschen machen in
der politik auch in anderen
lebensbereichen ständige ohnmacht
erfahrungen ja diesem versprechen wir
gestalten unser gemeinwesen folgen keine
taten weil die möglichkeiten super
beschränkt sind und aus diesen
widerspruch ergibt sich politische
erschöpfung aber bei diesen bei diesen
enttäuschungen liegt der schwarze peter
möglicherweise ja auch in der
gesellschaft selbst man erwartet von den
politikern politikerinnen und politikern
offenheit authentizität transparenz
sie haben das mal dann die klartext
falle genannt und gleichzeitig wird man
wenn man dann klartext redet viele jahre
daraufhin fest genau das in wahlkämpfe
hinein wird dann sozusagen ein stereotyp
einer bestimmten person gegeben du hast
ja damals dass uns das gesagt und
deswegen bist du nicht mehr
vertrauenswürdig diese inkonsequenz
etwas zu erwarten dass aber gleichzeitig
dann gleich zu verdammen macht ja
eigentlich politisches handeln das
nachvollziehbar ist dass auch rückhalt
in der bevölkerung hat fast unmöglich ja
sie haben dann im grund genommen jeweils
nur schlechte möglichkeiten sie können
versuchen das problem irgendwie
abzustreiten sie können inszeniert
inszenatorisch hochrüsten und sich mit
noch besseren pr beratern umgeben aber
das merken die leute auch sie können
sich in den plastik sprech
flüchten oder sie können wir haben ja
beispiele aus wahlkämpfen und leute
unter stress dinge tun gästen machen
fotos produzieren sie können dinge tun
die sie dann nachher bereuen und da ist
diese ich nenne es jetzt mal die habe
geantwortet
diese sozusagen schmerzens arbeit vor
publikum das publikum somit nimmt
erklärt und wege zeigt nicht resultate
verkündet sondern prozesse sichtbar
macht der suchende fragende nicht der
resultat hafte stil der als aus meiner
sicht da schon eine antwort aber sie
dürfen es eben auch nicht überdosiert in
dem moment in dem dann zuviel privatheit
dann würde man sich fragen wo sind wir
jetzt ja eigentlich und würde wieder in
anderer weise
fragen also es ist eine permanente ein
permanentes arbeiten mit dilemmata das
hier gefordert ist also wenn ich
ergänzen dafür vielleicht gar nicht nur
zu viel privatheit sondern auch zu viel
zu viele fragen also irgendwann will der
wähler will der bürger die bürger dann
auch eine antwort haben und auch nicht
zu viel korrigieren also habe ich hatte
meine bestimmte zeit wo sich alle paar
tage korrigiert hat und entschuldigt hat
und gesagt hat er habe sich tierisch
geärgert das war dann auch im punkt zu
viel was ich als entscheidenden
unterschied zwischen der kommunikation
von olaf scholz und von den grünen sehe
ist diese frage wie spricht man den den
bürger an und da sehe ich bei den grünen
dieses diesen diesen eindruck man
spricht mit sozusagen erwachsenen
menschen ja also dem mündigen bürger den
man auch was zutraut also die grünen
haben ja diese these die gesellschaft
ist viel weiter als die politik glaubt
und das setzen sie auch in der
kommunikation um so bewerte ich das
jedenfalls und und trauen dem dem volk
zu bestimmte dilemma zu verstehen ja
erklären dass auch aber und es ist ja
ehrlich gesagt auch so viele also selbst
also breite teile der gesellschaft nicht
nur die berliner elite versteht es ja
auch wenn man es einfach erklärt es ist
ja auch am ende runtergebrochen auf die
idee die basics ist es ja auch nicht so
kompliziert und olaf scholz dagegen hat
diese relativ überhebliche art also das
ist nicht nur dieses zitat jungs und
mädels ja sondern auch diese ich weiß
wie es geht und ich werde das jetzt kurz
erklären und auch ein bisschen dieses
gefühl sakrosankt zu sein also kritik
nimmt er ja dann sehr persönlich
reagiert ja teilweise fast trotzig und
das steht schon im großen gegensatz und
dieser diese ideen nicht nur mitzunehmen
sondern auch zuzutrauen ja entscheidung
nachzuvollziehen entscheidung
mitzutragen kommt meine ich sehr gut an
und das ist eine form von moderner
politik die wenn es gut läuft sich
vielleicht durchsetzen sollen bei der
abteilung neid wenn ihr als die grünen
so eine gute performance haben und die
fdp und manche in der spd schwindet
bereits der kann dass das so gut
berlin funktioniert und den eigenen
parteien und in der eigenen performance
nicht so gut ist dass eine gefahr für
die ampel ja also zwei sachen zum einen
haben die grünen die bittere erfahrung
gemacht dass sie immer zwischen waren
sehr gut da stehen also jetzt schon
mehrfach sodass man sich also der satz
gesagt davon momentan sehr viel kaufen
kann sondern das kann auch wie wir es so
wir haben 20 21 gesehen sehr schnell
ganz anders kommen insofern so was man
aber natürlich beobachten kann nachdem
jetzt landtagswahlen ist schon dass es
jedenfalls in gewisse gefahr gibt wo die
grünen auch derzeit sehr stark gegen
steuern also die gefahr von neid die
gefahr von instabilität dass sie sich
zum beispiel nach der wahl in nordrhein
westfalen sehr zurückhaltend gefreut
haben ja und also diese idee dass diese
koalition kann nur funktionieren wenn
man auch den anderen was gibt und da
sind sie ja nicht aufgetrumpft sondern
sie haben auch
gesagt das habe jetzt mit werbung und
habe gar nichts zu tun so sondern dass
sein ende das ergebnis aus dem land und
die fdp noch ein bisschen gelobt und
auch halb getröstet also es schon
interessant dass sich ein bewusstsein
dafür haben dass es brenzlig werden
könnte wenn nur einer grenzt und zwei
andere in die röhre gucken kann es sein
siegel dass man sich möglicherweise da
am anfang der ampel koalition also nach
ende der koalitionsverhandlungen dem
beginn der regierung stolz in der
ampelkoalition vielleicht auch ein
bisschen zu weit aus dem fenster gehängt
hat begrifflich da wurde von einer
fortschritts koalition gesprochen und
manche in der spd dachten aufgrund des
wahlergebnisses im september jetzt liegt
ein sozialdemokratisches sind an ähnlich
998 da haben die grünen von einer rot
gründen epoche gesprochen ziemlich genau
sieben jahre gedauert hat auch nur unter
mithilfe von edmund stoiber sonst nur
vier jahre gedauert sind das
begrifflichkeiten die man besser nicht
verwendet um auch eine überzogene
erwartungshaltung zu vermeiden hätte man
mich gefragt wie gesagt auf keinen fall
jetzt als glatte zu prallen das erste
dreier bündnis auf bundesebene eine
ampelkoalition mit zu großen
programmatischen unterschiede wurde dann
sozusagen nicht nur auf vier jahre
angelegt verkauft ob das politisch klug
ist das sei dahingestellt aber im
endeffekt ist ein punkt was jetzt ja
auch angesprochen wurde was die
kommunikation angehe
wir können nicht davon ausgehen so
radikal wie sich das
mediennutzungsverhalten in den letzten
fünfzehn bis zwanzig jahren ja selbst in
meiner alterskohorte verändert hat die
viele devices haben wir noch vielen
kanälen unterwegs sind sondern vor allem
bei den jungen menschen dass wir so
kommunizieren können wie gerhard
schröder das ist 1998 oder helmut kohl
1982 getan hat und deshalb ist dieser
ansatz in einer gesellschaft in der der
anteil der abiturienten stetig zunimmt
und auch der anteil der studierenden zu
nimmt dort stärker auf augenhöhe auch
vielleicht dilemma das klarzumachen
sicherlich einer der in die richtige
richtung geht gleichwohl haben wir
deutschland teil diese paradoxie auf
zwei ebenen
ich erwarte vom staat immer noch sehr
viel handlungsfreiheit und sehr viel
herrschaftsbereich und möchte aber
gleichzeitig möglichst wenig in meiner
individuellen lebensgestaltung
eingeschränkt werden und zweitens ich
möchte einen wohlfahrtsstaat wie in
schweden oder in dänemark möchte ich
aber eine steuerlast wie großbritannien
also diese widersprüchlichkeiten finden
wir bei vielen studien schon lange und
da müssen politiker sich entscheiden ob
sie eben bei der kommunikation ab und zu
klare kante zeigen auch die zweifel
deutlich machen oder versuchen stets
souverän zu wirken es wird immer
schwieriger nicht also man hat das ja
auch in der endphase von angela merkel
gesehen die übrigens mit sehr hohen
popularitätswerten freiwillige aus dem
amt ist wie sie heute auch noch mal zu
recht betont hat als einer der ganz
wenigen herrscher westeuropas aber man
hat schon auch gemerkt dass ein teil
ihrer kommunikation so ein bisschen aus
der zeit gefallen wirkt und das wird
natürlich jetzt nicht weniger so dass
dieser auf nach moderner kommunikation
der wird lauter werden und da müssen
sich auch politiker in der alterskohorte
von olaf scholz natürlich dem wandel der
zeit im studio hat das werden wir hier
auch in der phoenix runde weiter
beobachte ich bedanke mich bei der liga
prob ski bei bernhard pörksen bei hatten
und rosa und bei nico sie liebe
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
zwischen wunsch und wirklichkeit gehört
die ukraine in die europäische union
um 23 uhr kommt felix der tag mit alfred
schier bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]